♪ ♪
>> Greg: AS WE REALIZE WE ARE
IN THIS THING TOGETHER, PEOPLE
ARE STEPPING UP TO HELP EACH
OTHER.
A COLLEGE STUDENT LAUNCHED A
SHOPPING PROGRAM FOR AT-RISK
PEOPLE IN NEVADA, OTHERS HAVE
DONE SIMILAR THINGS ALL OVER
INCLUDING THIS YOUNG WOMAN.
>> THERE’S A VERY LARGE ELDERLY
COMMUNITY HERE AND I WAS WORRIED
THAT THE PEOPLE -- THOSE PEOPLE,
THOSE NEIGHBORS WEREN’T GETTING
WHAT THEY NEEDED.
I GOT AN EMAIL LAST NIGHT FROM A
MOM WITH A NEW BORN IN BROOKLYN
WHOSE HUSBAND IS SICK SO WE ARE
SETTING UP A GOOD START FOR HER
THIS MORNING.
I’VE HAD SO MANY PEOPLE REACH
OUT BOTH IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD TO
VOLUNTEER BUT ALSO ALL OVER THE
WORLD, SENDING ME THOSE SIGNS
THAT ARE MAKING WHICH I THINK IS
SO HUGE.
>> Greg: SHOULDN’T DOING GOOD
THINGS BE A COMPETITIVE SPORT
SINCE ALL THE OTHER ONES ARE
CANCELED?
A VIRTUE SIGNALING OLYMPICS BUT
WITH REAL VIRTUE.
NOT THE PHONY VIRTUE ON
SOCIAL MEDIA, ZERO COST WITH
ZERO BENEFIT.
IT’S ODD HOW OUR MOST FAMOUS
CELEBRITY CRUSADERS HAVE GONE
SILENT.
MY GUESS IS THEY ARE EITHER IN
GUARDED SECLUSION, AND I’M SURE
THE GUN-CONTROL ZEALOTS ARE
ARMED TO THE HILT.
AS FOR YOU, DO GOOD THINGS THAT
MAKE YOU FEEL GOOD.
GRANTED, IT’S HARD IN ISOLATION
BUT SMALL THINGS MATTER, WASHING
YOUR HANDS SHOULD MAKE YOU FEEL
HEROIC BECAUSE YOU’RE KILLING
GERMS AND SHARING, YES, EVEN
SHARING YOUR TOILET PAPER.
ONE GUY STARTED OUT TOILET PAPER
EXCHANGE ON A CALIFORNIA STREET
CORNER.
HIS HOMEMADE SIGN READ "SHARE
YOUR TOILET PAPER" AND IT’S
WORKING.
BECAUSE GOOD DEEDS MAKE YOU FEEL
LESS CRAPPY.
IT’S NOT VIRTUE SIGNALING BY
VIRTUE DOING.
WE SAW IDIOTS HOARDING TOILET
PAPER SO WHY NOT INITIATE GOOD
BEHAVIOR AND HOPE PEOPLE COPY
THAT, TOO?
THIS IS A GOOD TIME TO EAT
BETTER, EXERCISE MORE, PRACTICE
THE GUITAR GATHERING DUST ON THE
WALL, NOW’S THE TIME TO BE A
BETTER SELF.
THE OPPOSITE OF EVERY PANIC
IMAGINED BY HER ENTERTAINMENT
INDUSTRY.
PROVE THEM WRONG BY DOING THINGS
RIGHT ONCE AGAIN.
YOU ARE TELLING YOUR STORY ABOUT
A YOUNG BOY.
>> Dana: HE’S IN HIGH SCHOOL,
HE WAS THE SON OF ONE OF MY VERY
BEST FRIENDS IN THE WORLD AND
THEY LIVE UP IN WESTPORT AND HE
CREATED A WEB SITE, THEY CAME TO
HIM, ONE WESTPORT AND I THINK
THIS COULD HAPPEN ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY, BASICALLY IT’S A SITE
WHERE LOCAL BUSINESSES CAN SIGN
UP AND YOU CAN GO AND BUY MY
GIFT CARDS FOR THOSE BUSINESSES,
A ONE STOP SHOPPING PLACE.
I THINK THAT’S ALSO VERY
IMPORTANT, FIGURING OUT WHAT’S
NEEDED RIGHT HERE, DOWN IN
DALLAS, LET ME TRY TO DO
SOMETHING LIKE THAT, HOW CAN I
HELP IN MY COMMUNITY?
NOW UP IN SAN DIEGO, VIRGINIA,
IT’S CONTAGIOUS IN A GOOD WAY.
>> Greg: EXACTLY.
JESSE, WHEN YOU SEE PEOPLE ON
BLACK FRIDAY FIGHTING OVER
SOMETHING AND THEY DON’T KNOW
WHY, WHY CAN’T YOU REVERSE THAT
BEHAVIOR BY YOU, JESSIE, BEING
AN EXAMPLE IS A SELFLESS PERSON,
WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO FOR
AMERICA, JESSE?
>> Jesse: I RECOGNIZE A CRY
FOR HELP WHEN I SEE ONE AND I
KNOW YOU’RE AT AND AT RISK AGE
SO THIS IS WHAT I’M GOING TO DO,
I’M GOING TO LEAVE THE SHOW AND
GO GROCERY SHOPPING FOR YOU,
YOU’RE GOING TO MAKE ME A LIST,
GET WHATEVER YOU WANT, RIBS,
T-BONE, I WILL BRING IT TO YOUR
DOORSTEP, YOU DON’T HAVE TO GET
OUT OF YOUR HOUSE, I WILL JUST
BRING IT TO YOUR DOORSTEP, I
DON’T WANT TO GET TOO CLOSE AND
YOU CAN HAVE WHATEVER YOU WANT
FOR DINNER.
I WILL EVEN GO TO THE PHARMACY
AND GET YOUR PRESCRIPTION DRUGS.
OKAY?
WE KNOW YOU NEED YOUR MEDS, I
WILL BE THERE TO SAVE YOU FROM
YOURSELF AND THAT IS THE WAY I
AM GOING TO BE HELPING OUT
AMERICA.
IN ALL SERIOUSNESS, THOUGH,
IVANKA TRUMP HAS A HASHTAG,
SHE’S DOING A LOT OF THE THINGS
YOU’RE TALKING ABOUT EVEN IF
YOUR HOME ALONE, YOU SPEND MORE
TIME WITH YOUR SPOUSE AND HELP
THE NEIGHBORS, MANY THINGS ONE
CAN DO AT A TIME WHEN WE ARE
APART, COME TOGETHER.
>> Greg: THE UPSIDE TO NOT
HAVING KIDS, YOU HAVE A LOT OF
LEFT OVER CASH.
>> Juan: TELL ME ABOUT IT, I
SPENT MINE.
>> Greg: I CAN THROW MONEY AT
PROBLEMS.
IF YOU HAVE A PROBLEM, JUST
DON’T EMAIL ME, OKAY?
WHAT ARE YOU DOING TO MAKE THE
WORLD A BETTER PLACE?
>> Juan: I THINK YOU SHOULD
HAVE CALLED THIS SEGMENT "I LOVE
THESE PEOPLE."
I HAVE BEEN PUSHING YOU, I
THINK, GOD IS GOING TO SMILE ON
YOU, GREG, YOU SAY "I LOVE THESE
PEOPLE" AND YOU LOVE WHAT THESE
YOUNG PEOPLE ARE DOING.
I THINK THAT’S A GREAT IDEA.
THE ONE THING I WOULD SAY TO YOU
IS EVEN IF JESSE COMES TO HELP
YOU, THERE IS STILL PLACE FOR
GOVERNMENT AND INSTITUTIONS THAT
WE TRUST TO RESPOND TO THIS
CRISIS.
AFTER 9/11, WE NEEDED GOVERNMENT
TO STEP UP AND DO ITS THING AND
WE NEED GOVERNMENT RIGHT NOW TO
STEP UP AND TAKE CONSTRUCTIVE
ACTION TO HELP US ALL.
WE CAN TALK ABOUT INDIVIDUALS
BUT I DON’T THINK WE SHOULD
SOMEHOW -- THE LIBERTARIAN BENT
AND YOU MAY SAY, GOVERNMENTS
ALWAYS BEST BUT I THINK
GOVERNMENT DOES PERFORM, IF
PERFORMED AFTER 9/11, WE WANT
GOVERNMENT AT ITS BEST RIGHT NOW
NOW.
>> Greg: THEY ALL COME
TOGETHER, PRIVATE AND GOVERNMENT
TOGETHER WORKING HAND IN.
>> Dana: BERNIE SANDERS WORST
NIGHTMARE.
>> Jesse:>> Greg: AM GOING TO ST
SINGING OF BARBRA STREISAND
SONG.
THERE IS A BIOLOGICAL RESPONSE
TO DOING GOOD STUFF, IT CAN BE
SELFISH BECAUSE IT MAKES YOU
FEEL BETTER.
>> Dr. Nicole: ACTUALLY, I
WORK AT ONE OF THE LARGEST
CANCER HOSPITALS IN OUR COUNTRY
AND I TELL YOU, THE VOLUNTEERS
THAT COME TO WORK THERE WHO HAVE
MAYBE NEVER VOLUNTEERED OTHER
TIME SAY THEY HONESTLY HAVE BEEN
THE HAPPIEST THEY’VE EVER BEEN
BECAUSE ALTHOUGH IT MAY BE HARD,
IT REALLY DOES GIVE THEM THE
POSITIVE FEEDBACK AND THEY
REALIZE THEY’RE DOING MORE SO I
THINK IT’S GREAT RECOVERING
THESE STORIES AND IT TAKES A
LITTLE BIT OF A DIFFERENT
APPROACH, PEOPLE LOVE TO LOOK IN
A BAD CAR CRASH BUT WE ARE ALL
ADDICTED TO THAT FOR SOME REASON
BUT IF WE CONTINUE TO SHOW THE
POSITIVE STORIES, THERE IS A
TRICKLE-DOWN EFFECT, TO MAYBE
HAVING OTHER PEOPLE DO IT AS
WELL.
EVEN IF YOU’RE GOING TO HELP
JUST ONE PERSON IT’S A GREAT
THING.
>> Dana: IF YOU HAVE PEOPLE IN
YOUR LIFE THAT YOU PAY ON AN
HOURLY BASIS LIKE A DOG WALKER
OR A TRAINER AND NOW THEY’RE NOT
ALLOWED TO COME TO YOUR BUILDING
OR THEY’RE SHELTERING IN PLACE,
IF YOU HAVE THE MEANS, CONTINUE
TO PAY THEM.
THE GOVERNMENT IS GOING TO HELP
BUT I THINK THAT IS SOMETHING,